salut aujourd'hui je suis avec toi ou là
où il était dans la vidéo chez beaucoup
mieux mais je vais mettre une petite
fiche là haut pour que vous puissiez
revoir la vidéo c'était aux
hallucinations collectives je suis chez
lui à limoges en mode matinale à toi ça
va m'aider à mes yeux le petit je me
suis pour aujourd'hui on va pas refaire
une vidéo où je suis un tour à taoussa
ou me fais un tour et puis en plus de ça
il y avait la vidéo dès hier que j'ai un
peu en travers de la gorge ce qui me
manquait des rushes et du coup j'ai pas
très fier de ce que je vous ai mis dans
la vidéo mais voilà pour le défi fallait
quand même que je la sorte malgré le peu
de rush que j'avais aujourd'hui en temps
normal je devrais faire un tour à
quelqu'un dont on va faire mieux que ça
puisque tao s'est proposé pour expliquer
un ou deux tours de magie c'est ça oui
aux mêmes trois ans ils sont sympa vous
savez quoi pour les tours je vous
prendre directement à la main comme ça
je vais pouvoir bien filmé de bien près
que vous puissiez bien comprendre dans
cette 9e vous connaissez tous ce fameux
porte fait ce qu'on appelle un
portefeuille avec une sécurité enfant ça
je vais on va pas trop s'éterniser
dessus mais c'est juste un petit tour
que je vais vous faire avec un petit
billet de 20 euros qu'on peut emprunter
comme fabien il n'a pas les moyens dont
elle même mois mais moi j'ai moi je sens
large en ligue 1 euro donc fait
classique tu peux fumer du prêtre une
fois que patrick et reproduisant un
verre est habillé widdergalm filigrane
en famille pour beaucoup moins bien
simplement je le pays de commencer on
voit bien là tu veux tu peux me lumière
des crayons classique par moussa je vais
commander en suisse en slow motion
regardez bien tu peut matériellement sur
six ans l'objet comme on dirait en
suisse en sociaux et bien j'ai tout
doucement je pénètre le biais toute la
saison
mais attention rien de bien j'ai ça
arrive à vous voir ici tu as bien tout à
fait monsieur plan bien intérieurs si
c'est ce qu'on appelle dans le monde 2
financière d'avoir un trou dans son
budget d'accord mais si vicieux de
traverser complètement le crayon à
travers et là le seul moyen de pouvoir
réparer se trouve vous avez le budget ce
soit datant de la fin du mois depuis
deux mois ou alors faire prendre le
crayon comme une baguette magique gear
la formule non pas abracadabra mais pour
les tours avec des billets vous dire
juste cahuzac
m et au bout d'un moment la pression
amazing mais j'ai envie de vous dire
mais comment ça fonctionne je ne sais
pas du tout il faut une toute petite
préparation situe fine la juste un tout
petit une petite france tout fait ça ou
au cutter soit le grand que tu te moques
émoi national
le triangle at on pourrait bien ok voilà
donc un taux faille j'ai juste après le
le filet grave crise qui me permet en
fait quand je pileux villiers montrer
qu'il ya une bonne marge là et le mans
devra vraiment que le crayon ne fasse
pas derrière est ce que si ceux ci ont
fait ça on a vraiment l'impression que
ça passe derrière alors que si un
décalage
tu prends le crayon qui fait cela est
derrière que je montre que ce qui se
passe du côté magicien pas qu'ici ça
passe ici dans le trou de face ça fait
ça on vraiment lui disons que ça
l'intérieur a l'avantagé que on peut
tenir le crayon comme ça pendant la
séduction que cette traverse la partie
qu'on a envie d' examiner c'est là
exactement 1 cc oo c'est vraiment mieux
d'oublier alors que la fente est en
décalage quand vous appuyez le billet
l'ailé demain les de douala sont sur la
franqui l'été et qui est juste là qui
fait que sa cage qu'il est temps d'en
tirer le jeu s'est reconstituée donc
quand tu dis bien emprunté tu te [ __ ]
de nous on peut l'emprunter
mais vous préparez vous allez vous allez
vite fait avec votre au cutter mais
c'est non on est là seulement que le
véritable bilan
je prends juste six sachets de sucre et
si ses parents on peut rien faire une
personne pas si tu peux tendre eu
d'états d'âme on y regarde tu préfères
lequel sachet celui ci se sont massés
alors là on va l'utiliser pour vraiment
pour la caméra tu ne vas quand j'en suis
là tu peut le vérifier que tu as
vraiment le sucre aussi bien jeumont
cécile à la main pour les médias pas de
fpc père ouvrier
parce que promettent un pouce bleus
jouent entre égaler toutefois le vert
regardez pas cela dans les centres et
justement posta et si vous croyez fort
thomas gilou l'amant si on chauffe un
peu la matière tout doucement avec les
mains rien qu'avec j'ai la chaleur
humaine de vraiment essayé d impression
tout le monde que tous les grains de
sucre disparaissent ici totalement quand
vous avez le cutter et on allait
toujours de dans les toilettes et vous
faites une petite fente sur un sachet de
sucre que vous avez pris au comptoir du
bar se sucrent là vous allez vous en
débarrasser du par les toilettes voilà
directement
on fait donc plus grande histoire de
vous montrer que pour combien la vidéo
parce que ils se saoulent équipe là est
donc celui que vous avez vidé vous en
gardez un tout petit peu quand même pour
pour montrer qu'à la fin il ya du suc là
et quand vous avez le deuxième jeu vous
secouer là vraiment la pression quelques
dés de ça chez elle parce qu'on entend
le bruit de l'autre sachez alors si vous
regardez dans la vidéo on le voit voilà
et après vous avez aussi choisi c'est à
celui qui évite de préférence et là
comme ça ne doit pas vous déchirer ce
qui fait que ça élimine mais la
préparation la france 2 a été comme ça
moi c'est examine abl vous posez ça fait
seulement d'ouvrir cissé ou montré bien
que l'ama est vide ou versé tout ça et
comme il reste quelques grains de sucre
ça vous permet de vraiment me della
bella - tac
on a vraiment l'impression que tout le
sachet de sucre disparaît alors moi je
connaissais la version tu fais avec le
spectateur
ouais avec la personne et les deux
déchire en même temps les deux mètres
dans leurs mains en même temps sauf que
à la fin le magicien n'a plus rien et le
spectateur à plein de trucs dans le mag
du sud c'est un petit truc marrant à
faire à la fin du repas qu mais point
nommé raisons de budget fond n'avait pas
tort sonné mais ça tombe bien que tu me
dis ça parce qu'ils en revanche et nice
autre chose qui tient la caméra
je tiens à ce que vous savez que sur la
semelle n'arrête jamais mais jamais
jamais voir on n'est pas lâcher des
bombes et le temps donc comme ça vient
des 10 et le spectateur fait les choses
donc j'imagine que c'est moi qui joue le
rôle dévastateur
je fais ça l'a donc y verse dans sa main
la photo on voit vraiment vraiment de
sucre ici je te plains bon madame fera
le ménage
donc là on voit le succès tant ce qui
fait que le spectateur il reste comme un
com comment on pourrait dire en face à
la mannschaft chemin voilà exact est
plein plapla la plage ils ouvrent et le
problème c'est que plein de sueur alors
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire bien on
pourrait enchaîner avec ça au lieu de
reculer gâchis ya du gâchis
ouais donc en fait on dit à la personne
de mettre le sucre dans une casse
tout doucement je peux leur faire voir
ailleurs excuse moi voilà
ok la cclat d'accord tu peux bien filmé
manger un peu de sucre on va mettre sur
la table suis moi ok est ce qu'on
appelle une routine en magie c'est en
fait une combinaison de plusieurs
numéros on a fait disparaître le sucre
les spectateurs tient toujours le sucré
au lieu de ne rien faire avec
il le met dans 7 à vous montrer
maintenant qu'on peut faire des dommages
y avait à de la magie également avec ça
suffit de montrer gilet de ma [ __ ]
attention des prêts fabien rey je mets
juste maintenant en dessous de ses
pareils toujours avec la chaleur humaine
on fait ça et si on fait ça on se cogne
qui pesait devoir coppola en manque
si vous croyez à la magie on peut
transformer ici le sucre en café rivière
tout doucement je vais tous vous n'y a
pas de coupure de caméras et ça c'était
vraiment un impressionnant des cafés
solubles à la place du sucre et les
bombes de café elles game c'est beaucoup
l'explication est automatique
vous prenez du sucres solubles saluant
gras tu peux filmer un talon mais
manquant pas compris si c'est du gros
gras il faut prendre un faux pas
surprendre celui qui en poudre étant
donné que le grain est légèrement plus
gros tout le sucre d'envoyer le sucre et
les relais en dessous ok donc là ça soit
pas donc là la tasse et préparer l
avance avec le real le cajellon toi tu
mets le sucre parodie du lac te ment
donc on va à la hauteur des dirigeants
pour montrer que les spectateurs et là
vous voulez dit que tu mets le sucre
intérieur comme ça que les gens
n'auraient pas ce qu'il ya le fond une
fois que tu as vu qu'ils avaient le
sucre ça ça va recouvrir tous les gars
avant la vue d'amener devant les actes
et après vous êtes plus calmes et de
votre main comme si vous étiez vraiment
dans son coin légèrement prenez un peu
de force centrifuge exactement et
ouvrait la main le sucre a disparu ça
devient vraiment du cas t on à 38
minutes de vidéo on va s'arrêter là
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère que ça vous aura plus que
c'était clair n'hésitez pas à le refaire
pour bluffer des gens
un petit peu si ces tournois vous ont
plu n'hésitez pas à nous faire savoir en
laissant un petit pouce en l'air ou
également vous abonner à la chaîne
n'oubliez pas le mental blog c'est une
vidéo par jour pendant un an donc rendez
vous demain à 17 heures pour le prochain
rappel blary ciao